foreign
[Music]
let's get this show on the road we are
okay so we we do get we do get white
again
it's against Morad uh the fourth that's
a pretty imposing name we're gonna play
one E4 uh we did a brief Excursion a
couple of games ago played the jababa
London but now we are back to our main
openings and I think it's more exciting
now because we're playing pretty high
rated folks and you know we're gonna see
if my opening recommendations actually
hold up at a higher level
of course the main opening
recommendation is the alopin Sicilian
which we are going to play and at this
level I would say 1700 plus almost
everybody has a line against the allop
and they've studied the Elephant at one
point or another but typically what I
found is that they might know you know
three or four moves of theory they might
know the basic ideas but that's what
makes the allopin so dangerous it's not
enough for black to just know you know
the basics of the first couple of moves
the theory goes for a long time and
black can get crushed even with prior
knowledge of certain variations so okay
enough talk D5 of course is the main
move we've already faced it a couple of
times in this Speed Run we take on D5
okay and this is the second time that
we're facing the move Knight to F6
what's hilarious is that okay those
watching on YouTube I don't know if my
editor is going to put that initial
segment in the video but before I
started this game I got paired again
against an opponent that I had already
played before and I aborted that game
that opponent had been facing me with
black and he had played the move Knight
F6 so you can find that game in the
speedrun and after that game concluded I
took out the elephant Bible uh the
caliphun book and we actually checked
what kalofun's recommendation was
against Knight F6 so this is going to be
you know opening Improvement in action
you might remember that Bishop B5 check
was my choice in the first game that we
faced this line but I remember
distinctly that kalaphman recommends the
move Queen to A4 check so the move is
Queen A4 check and we're gonna play it
what on Earth is the the Zen behind
Queen A4 check well the idea of this
move is exactly the same as the idea
behind Bishop E5 check it's to force a
piece to appear on D7 why are we forcing
a piece to appear on D7 well the main
reason is to cut the contact between
Black's queen and the pawn on D5 to make
this Pawn harder to win back now of
course Queen D7 runs into Bishop B5 and
black loses on the spot so the move
Bishop D7 is technically a developing
move so you might say well why are we
helping black develop with Tempo but
remember not all developing moves are
necessarily good just because a piece
moves out of its initial Square doesn't
necessarily mean that that's a good
thing and here it's most definitely not
a good thing where should the queen go
back to that's the first big question of
course we go back to B3 and three things
happen the first is that we're attacking
B7 the second is that black cannot
recapture on D5 precisely because the
bishop intercepts the Queen's connection
with the pawn and the third thing is
that the Knight on B8 no longer has a
good developing Square it can come out
to A6 potentially but you can tell how
awkward of a developing move that is
so the reason we don't play Queen C4 is
because we want to hit that tender Pawn
on B7 the second reason is that we want
to reserve the C4 Square for the bishop
Queen C4 would be kind of stepping on
The Bishop's toes and C4 is a much more
vulnerable Square for the queen it can
be pretty easily attacked with a move
like B5
okay Queen B6
our opponent might be aware of the
theory here I'm pretty hazy on the
theory at this point I remembered Queen
A4 Queen B3 but at this point I'm
basically on my own so let's try to
think logically and see if we can
maintain an advantage so first of all I
don't want to take on B6 I don't want to
give black the open a file and pressure
on the A2 Pawn you might be aware of
many openings in which Queens on B3 and
B6 are standard in the London system
this is incredibly common and typically
as hopefully you know you're actually
not supposed to be the one to release
the tension because that opens up an a
file now that can be used to pressure
the queen size so I would play yeah
Bishop C4 I think is kind of a
no-brainer here because we developed the
bishop we reinforced the pawn and we
toss the ball right back into Black's
court if our opponent takes on B3
remember that concrete considerations
always take precedence over following
general principles so the general
principle would seem to indicate that we
should recapture it with the pawn but if
you look very carefully recapturing with
a pawn would be a mistake because black
has the move B7 B5 hitting our Bishop
the bishop doesn't have B3 anymore and
so we will end up losing the pawn on D5
back
so in fact if our opponent would have
taken on B3 we would have recaptured uh
with the bishop and tried to maintain
our extra Pawn Knight A6 I think is a
good move what does our opponent want
well first of all he's just developing
the Knight but I think he's trying to
swing this Knight back to sc7 in order
to put more pressure on the D5 pawn and
ideally we don't want to give that pawn
away without a serious fight so let's
consider the various Methods at our
disposal to keep this Pawn alive or to
attack something and distract Black's
attention from the D5 Pawn
so what comes to mind here I actually
have to think for a couple moments here
this is not an easy position
I have one idea that's pretty
straightforward
but I'm looking for something better of
course I've forgotten completely what
Call of Fun's recommendation is I'm
pretty sure this position did occur in
our first video in which this line was
played against me but of course I've
forgotten everything okay so I can't
find a clear way to stop Knight C7 the
idea of 92 Knight C7 Knight F4 came to
my mind but the problem is that the
Knight can be chased away with the move
G5
although after G5 maybe the Knight can
swing back to D3 and put pressure on C
but this all seems very speculative and
if our Knight lands on D3 then how are
we going to get our Bishop out how are
we going to get our other night out nah
I don't want to get too greedy here
instead
we're going to take a slightly different
approach we're going to say okay it's
going to take black two moves to play
Knight C7 and Knight takes D5 in those
two moves we are going to try to secure
a different kind of positional Advantage
so what we're going to do is we're going
to trade in our material advantage for a
positional Advantage what positional
Advantage can we acquire here where I
see a way that we can acquire the bishop
pair we can acquire the bishop Pair by
going after the D7 Bishop how can we go
after the D7 Bishop well first of all we
play Knight F3 this is a move that you
should probably play even if you don't
know what your follow-up is going to be
Knight F3 is just
you know a priori a good move because it
develops the Knight and prepares
castling but after Knight C7 I think a
critical moment arises
now first of all what is black
threatening after Knight C7 it's not
Knight takes D5 because then we play
Bishop takes D5 after Knight C7 black
threatens to trade queens and only then
to recapture the pawn just a little
clarification that I wanted to make
but it's probably not a good idea for
black to take the queen first because in
that case we Again Play Bishop takes B3
and if black plays Knight C7 there we
can actually reinforce we can reinforce
the D5 Pawn with a move C4 but I think
it's important for black to actually go
Knight C7 here move order is always
super crucial in these complicated
positions
now D6 a lot of you are very attracted
by but look at it more carefully black
doesn't have to play e takes D6 and give
up F7 with check in response to D6 black
takes on B3
and neither DC nor de come with check so
we're going to have to recapture the
queen and black just plays e takes D6
we've given black the pawn with interest
so what move have I been hinting at
continuously how do we go after the
bishop pair
well the move should be pretty obvious
too once I point that out uh we can play
the move d4 yeah D4 comes to mind but I
don't really see what it accomplishes
exactly D4 black blaze Queen takes B3
Bishop takes B3 C takes D4
okay you trade on D4 black takes on D5
and I feel like we have a completely
equal end game I think more meat on the
bone is yielded by the move 95 this is a
challenging move because it goes after
the bishop pair you might say well is
the bishop here really that important in
the end game well I will try to prove to
you that it is I think our possession of
an uncontested light squared Bishop is
going to yield dividends in the end game
but I'm not entirely sure
so I will admit that I'm not positive
that this is the right approach to the
position but it's pretty risk-free I
mean we're essentially forcing a
slightly better end game and there are
worse things in life than a slightly
better end game
okay Knight F7 is not even a threat if
you think about it because after King F7
you guys want D6 check I see the
temptation but the knight from C7 can
cover the check on E6 remember when you
give a discover check uh check whether
the piece that you're attacking cannot
itself block the check that's just an
item on the checklist you always have to
go through give a discover check let's
say to a queen can the queen itself move
away and block the check
you know
okay what should we take back with well
of course the situation has changed and
we're we've already agreed uh to part
ways with our D5 Pawn so the previous
logic of taking back with a bishop is
kind of null and void at this point
right because we're going to lose the
pawn anyway so we might as well Garner
as many advantages as as we can before
it's too late
so from that perspective a takes B3
actually makes a lot of sense to open up
the a file
going down the the logic that I
described earlier on the other hand
Bishop takes B3 keeps our Pawn structure
intact but I want to play with a little
bit more spice so let's take with a pawn
and this is of course Very typical
across many many different types of
openings and I'll give you a couple
examples after the game so if you're
watching this on YouTube and you know
you're newer to chess and you hear me
say oh this is typical in oh these
openings and you don't know what I'm
talking about don't feel you don't feel
bad I'll usually try to educate you a
little bit about some of the
similarities after the game
so of course black can greatly diminish
the pressure
along the a file with a well-timed A6
but remember it's not just the pressure
on the A7 Pawn that we have it's also
squares for the A1 Rook the move Rook A1
to A5 can come at a very inconvenient
moment for black we can hit C5 and just
Square control is good in and of itself
the fact that the Rook has all these
squares restricts Black's mobility in
certain ways I'm not saying that it's a
game changer but these small advantages
they accumulate and when you hit this
level 1900 2000 it's very hard to win
right out of the opening a lot of games
aren't decided any longer by big
tactical blunders they're decided by an
accumulation of smaller positional
advantages that taken together allow you
to outplay your opponent so in this case
we have two distinct advantages right
now we have an extra Pawn but we won't
have that presumably after Black's next
move
so the First Advantage is the bishop
pair that we're going to have to retake
97 and the second Advantage is we have
control over better control over the a
file
we need to gather more advantages
but that'll come in due time
there is one small problem with the move
that I just played if this is in fact a
problem
it might turn out after the game that
Bishop takes B3 was more advisable I
actually think this is what our opponent
is contemplating currently it's not
these are all very minor details but
there there might be a way for black to
keep his two Bishops and that is the
move Bishop to F5 which some of you have
suggested in my naivete I thought that
it meets with D6 discover attack against
the F7 Pawn but I didn't calculate far
enough Bishop F5 D6 e takes D6 Knight E5
takes F7 who can tell me the move that I
missed from a distance
and why it's good
yeah perturb is on fire D6 D5
now you might say but don't we take the
rook in the corner and doesn't black
only have one minor piece for the Rook
that's true but the Knight on h8 is also
going to get trapped and white has a
couple of extra Pawns in that line as
well so I'm not totally sure how to
evaluate that position but it gets very
complicated and I don't want to give our
opponent unnecessary tactical chances in
an end game where we're enjoying our
life Bishop F5 played okay
so let's deal with this new set of
circumstances again Knight takes F7 King
takes F7 D6 check doesn't work because
of 96 so I will admit that I missed this
move and I think we've lost our
advantage that means we're playing an
equal end game there are worse things in
life than an equal end game let's try to
outplay our opponent okay
so let me think here for just a moment
because there's many ways to to play
this position we're running a little bit
low on time
so the situation
is is is very complex
I have an interesting idea so
I'm basically looking at this position
saying okay well we haven't completed
our development that's the biggest
priority what pieces have we not
developed yet well obviously we should
castle at some point but we should also
consider developing Our Queen side but
we should be careful about how we do it
because if you play the move D3 the
bishop is actually going to get trapped
by the move B5 so I'm also looking at
the Knight on B1 and I'm asking myself a
what can we offer for the night and I'm
actually noticing the move Knight to A3
which is a very interesting idea that
night can head to B5 if you play the
allopin consistently this should be
intuitive too Knight A3 Knight B5 is a
super typical maneuver across different
sub-variations of the alopin and it can
be very problematic for black as I think
it is here the move Knight B5 is going
to be pretty darn unpleasant for black
yeah of course the A6 A6 counters Knight
B5 but the Knight can also drop back to
C2 the Knight on A3 actually has a lot
of prospects it can go back toward the
center through C2 to E3 and A6 does
spend a tempo
and what I want you to realize is that
even if black plays A6 The Rook on A8 is
defended by the Knight on C7 but if that
Knight moves for example to take the
pawn we could still play Knight B5
that's one of the benefits the hidden
benefits of having the open a file
so presumably if if our opponent played
A6 we would just Castle short and try to
force black to put his cards on the
table
A6 played we castle kingside and we kind
of sit tight
now I'm a little bit I was a little bit
worried about the move B5
um I was a little bit worried about the
move B5
Bishop E2 followed by B4 so that's a
little bit worrisome
um it's a little bit worrisome
so we'll see if our opponent expands on
the queen side with B5
or or or takes takes the pawn on D5 and
if he takes on D5 then of course the big
question is which Knight will he take
with
but there there's a lot that more than
meets the eye in this position a lot of
like hidden tactics here that
hopefully I'll be able to explain in
Greater depth after the game
I will confess though I haven't played
great so far
I'm pretty disappointed at my move a
takes B3 like Bishop B3 would have been
a lot better because it would have paved
the way for the C Pawn to move up to C4
which would have forced Black's hand it
would have forced black to take the pawn
then we would have secured the bishop
air and we would have been solidly
better
but that's in the past now Knight takes
D5 okay
so how do we proceed
seed
now of course we can already play Knight
B5 the issue is that Knight B5 does not
create any threats right it it looks
pretty but where is the Knight actually
going to go from B5 I don't see any
further squares because C7 is guarded by
black snipe
um so we need to find some way to sort
of open up well we need to open up the
dark squared Bishop at some point so D4
comes to mind but that leads to an
isolated Queen Pawn situation where
black has control of the square in front
of the pawn can we add a little bit of
Tabasco sauce to this position that's
kind of what we need we need to move
that really mix this things up in some
way I have an idea this is a risky move
but it's an interesting move
I'm noticing that the two nights are
linked up right so anytime there's
contact between one of your pieces and
one of your opponent's pieces you know
the drill you have to consider that from
a tactical perspective if hypothetically
there was a way to chase away the Knight
on F6 that would be really good that
would even win a piece oh when I start
saying that hopefully your eyes are kind
of automatically drawn to the right side
of the board
literally and figuratively the move is
G4 the move that I have in mind now it's
not that risky because it's an end game
and we're not too worried about the
weakness of our King we're forcing black
to make a difficult decision here
because G5 is a huge threat as is G
takes F5 so the bishop has to find a
place to go
let's see where our opponent drops back
to
yeah I can play D3 by the way D3 is now
possible because as we've already
established B5 runs into Knight takes B5
but the additional drawback of playing
D3 is that black throw could move away
from A8 and that would reinforce the
threat of B5
on the Scoville unit this is you know a
little spicier than Tabasco
a little spicier than Tabasco
now we might be going the wrong
direction here and this might be a
terrible move but I really don't think
it is
and I I really cannot emphasize enough
that I'm I'm exaggerating when I say
that it's a risky it's really not all
that risky because the Queens are off
the board
so I'm not anticipating getting
checkmated here really I'm not and that
should be pretty clear to you just
because of the fact that black is also
very undeveloped
so I don't see a way for black to whip
up a sudden attack on our King it's much
more dangerous to play this move when
the Queens are on the board
time is getting kind of low here this
has been a very very complicated first
12 moves and I don't anticipate things
to get any less complex
okay so Bishop E6 of course is the
correct move what have we accomplished
by forcing the bishop back to E6 well
we've accomplished one main thing which
is that we've buried we've buried the
bishop on f8 we've bought ourselves a
couple more Tempe for the development of
our pieces and we have forced the black
Bishop off of F5 what was the bishop
doing on F5 well it was controlling the
C2 Square why is that important well
because I mentioned when we played the
move Knight A3 that B5 isn't the only
promising Prospect for the Knight we can
also drop the Knight back to C2 and as
lame as a retreating move may appear the
Knight on C2 is actually a very well
placed piece in the elephant for two
reasons the first is that it can move
toward the center with Knight E3 the
second is that it can prepare the pawn
push D2 D4 and if we play D4 with a
knight on C2 things start getting dicey
for black in the center especially with
the King side as undeveloped as it is
notice also that uh that black is not
threatening to take on G4 that's still
to doesn't work but we have to figure
out the correct move order should we
play the move G5 I don't think we should
because that only helps black remove our
active knight from the board I think we
should go Knight C2 I think we should go
Knight C2 we're rerouting and we're
preparing the move d4 and we're clearing
the a file so hopefully you're able to
see that Bishop to B5 check in some
circumstances could be a pretty nasty
move for black
uh Knight of nard says why not be I
don't really understand B4 C takes B4 I
don't really see what that accomplishes
I mean it kind of ruins the pawn
structure and the idea of pushing B5
seems a little bit too slow
yeah I have a feeling that this game
might at least partially be decided on
the clock because each game is taking us
each move is taking us like you know a
minute okay oh
I forgot the black could do that
I completely forgot the black could do
that
all right so what's happening here
I don't think it's that good for black
to be honest I feel like the king and
the queen side is actually pretty
vulnerable and it could get attacked
with a potential sacrifice on A6 even
with the Queen's off the board
Bishop takes A6 could potentially be a
pretty dangerous move
um now it's important to establish that
with his last move black is reinforced
the threat of Knight takes G4 why is it
now a threat because the Rook defends
the Knight so it's a threat so H3 comes
to mind but H3 is too slow I really feel
intuitively that every Tempo matters in
a position like this so really even
without calculating I want to strike
with D4 before black has a chance to
complete his development so is there a
way to defend this Pawn with Tempo there
sure is there's the straightforward move
G5 attacking the Knight and on the next
move basically regardless of where black
puts tonight we're gonna strike at the
center with D4
and then things get really really spicy
entirely possible that objectively white
is worse here but I feel like
practically with Black's King side not
yet developed the situation becomes very
difficult to handle with black
no we're not gonna pre-move I mean I you
our opponent has thrown some Crow Buzz
at us so I'm gonna err on the side of
caution here
I mean why would white be worse here
well the main reason would be the pawn
structure which has been seriously
damaged by our Cavalier play make no
mistake I pointed out that G4 G5 is not
particularly risky from a king safety
perspective but it is risky from a pawn
structure perspective I mean you should
see that it creates major Square
weaknesses on the king side and the G5
Pawn is itself now a weakness until it
is supported by H4 it can also be used
as a hook by black to try to open up the
H file and activate the Rook with a move
like H6 you're probably familiar with
this idea in the context of attacking
of course don't fall asleep on our Queen
Side Pawn structure which is also very
much subpar so trades in general are
going to favor Black here we're gonna
try to keep as many pieces on the board
as possible
but My worry is that this game might be
decided on the clock and I don't want
that to be the case because this is
actually super super interesting end
game thus far but that's also part of
realistic chess
right when you create complications
right out of the opening you force your
opponent to take a ton of time and
that's just a legitimate thing that that
does actually happen Knight D7 good move
so our opponent is targeting our most
active piece and unfortunately
we can't have our cake and eat it too
either we get D4 and or we preserve our
Knight it's not both now we definitely
should not play D4 here because black
can then initiate the trade and take the
teeth out of the Pawn on D4 which shifts
to E5 so of course we should trade
Knights first and this is basically a
no-brainer then we immediately push D4
really without thinking further
and this is starting to look pretty darn
decent for white because we are
attacking the C5 Pawn this is the
benefit of playing against your
opponent's lack of development if black
could play the move E6 here he would be
totally fine but I don't see an easy way
for black to do that
Bishop F5 I guess that is the easy way
to do that but is it an easy way to do
that I think that might have been a
subtle tactical mistake I think Bishop
to H3 followed by E6 might have been the
way to do it
okay why is it a subtle tactical mistake
well here I think things get very
concrete and I have no
listen I have no good way of explaining
how I just found what I found
of course throughout the game one of the
points of tension has been the Knight on
D5 you know that right that's kind of
why we played the move G4 earlier so
at every Point I've been kind of briefly
considering the captures right you're
just following the rules and considering
like the checks and the captures and
Bishop takes D5 is a move that you
should be considering even for a brief
instant on every move just like we
should consider it here Bishop takes D5
I think works out beautifully
because if black plays Rook takes D5
guess what our Knight lands on E3 and we
win the exchange because the Rook has no
squares along the fifth ring so our
opponent immediately accepts the
inevitable and takes C2 but now we take
F7 and that is a big big big Pawn that
is a big Pawn
because we're now threatening to drop
the bishop back to E6 which is why black
doesn't have time to take on D4
black also cannot play E5 here as cool
of a move as that appears because it
doesn't actually stop Bishop B6 black
has to burn a crucial tempo
either protecting the E6 square or
moving either The Rook or the king and
in all of those cases we get we can use
that Tempo to solve the problem of our
Center
yeah so for example I'm anticipating the
move Bishop C2 back to F5 that's like
the simplest way to defend E6 that gives
us a critical Tempo but we need to be
very
judicious about how we use that Tempo
because just starting to gobble up more
pawns like d takes E5 I think would be a
mistake here because it would finally
allow black to open up his King side
with E6 incidentally that also hits our
Bishop the bishop has to move Black's
Bishop recapture C5 and actually in that
resulting position black has very
serious compensation for the pawn
because we have all of these weaknesses
on the king side instead the sexy move
as some people in the chat are saying is
to play D5
and of course the idea is uh there's
only one idea we're preventing E6 we're
continuing to play against Black's King
side pieces making it as difficult as
possible to develop them why are we
preventing E6 well because we can just
play Pawn takes E6 or or even Bishop
takes E6 and we win a second Pawn
and you might say well okay what about
E6 Pawn take C6 or rookie seven doesn't
black win the six Pawn back and the
answer is no because we could bring our
Rook over to E1 at any moment white
should be technically winning here but
our opponent has played an excellent
game so we we have a lot of hard work
remains ahead of us
was rookie one instead in Fair yeah
rookie one instead didn't do any well
rookie one instead you're trying to
control the E6 square but notice that
the move rookie one doesn't prevent
black from playing E5
also you're blundering the D4 Pawn which
is currently attacked twice that was the
secondary idea which is that we were
black was threatening to take twice on
D4
you might look at this and well doesn't
that open the C file maybe we could have
sacrificed it and got Bishop E3 at the
end but again these are unnecessary
complications that we avoid with the
move D5
very importantly if black plays E5 we
can take on passant and simultaneously
defend the bishop
would Rook A5 have been good to ask Joey
that's a I love the fact that you
spotted that move unfortunately by
playing E6 black is also protecting the
C5 Pawn so Rook A5 would not have been
effective here
but again kudos for spotting that Rook
A5 is definitely a move that should be
on your radar because it hits the C5
Pawn
and on the previous move it even pinned
the pawn to the bishop so it comes close
to working
isn't onpassana hacking move could he be
banned for cheating so our opponent is
down to below two minutes and you know
you can sense that the game is starting
to slip away from him
but uh hopefully he puts up a Stern
resistance
but the bishop hangs right when black
plays E6 the bishop hangs
okay King d8
so does this move accomplish anything I
don't really think so
I don't see what it accomplishes does it
reinforce the threat of E6 no because we
still play D takes E6 now what is it
what does that tell us it tells us that
we are have time to play a general
improving move right a move that doesn't
necessarily create a huge threat but
that in some way improves our position
well what can we do to improve our
position well there's one thing that's
very obvious there's low hanging fruit
which is that our Bishop is not out yet
where should we put it well there are
two squares that seem appealing D2 is to
passive there's F4 and there's E3 both
of these moves have their appeal what I
like about Bishop to F4 is that it fully
restricts Black's Rook it covers uh the
Rooks two Escape squares and it actually
paralyzes black completely which is
crazy if you look at Bishop F4 carefully
the only way that black has of bringing
out the dark squirt Bishop is to play
the move G6 who can tell me how Bishop
F4 easy question how does it stop G6
how does it stop G6
yeah because then we can play Bishop E5
and The Rook is literally trapped
because G8 is controlled by the other
Bishop
so the more I look at it the more I like
the look of Bishop F4 Bishop E3 is also
excellent this was my initial intention
because it attacks C5 and C5 cannot
really be defended because B6 runs into
Rook takes A6 guess what this is what we
were talking about at the start which is
that even though the Rook quote-unquote
bites on granite the B7 Pawn is often
needed to defend its counterpart on C5
so we're actually putting tremendous
amounts of Queen side pressure but this
move is a freaking this is a GM move
Bishop F4 is definitely a GM move
because
as tempting as it is to hit the pawn
it's even better to paralyze your
opponent completely maybe bishop E3 is
better maybe we're getting too fancy but
I can't pass up this opportunity
what's amazing is that if black tries to
chip away at the edge with H6 we drive
the pawn down to G6 and that makes
things even worse then black is
completely entombed completely entombed
I mean black is already entombed
black is already entombed there's no
moves and look at this bishop G6 trying
to trade the Bishops whoop we drop back
to E6 and The Rook is trapped
the other benefit of putting the bishop
on F4
so all of you should be looking at this
and understanding why black is totally
paralyzed I mean it's not totally
zooxani because black can make a waiting
move and black can move the king back to
C8 but it's as close as it comes to
actual zuke's one during a game Bishop
C2 is a good move I think this is as
good of a chance as it gets
and now we can continue trying to play
healthy positional chess a bishop E6 is
very tempting I know but bear with me
for a second after Bishop E6 black takes
on B3 you might say well that's an
exchange yes you win an exchange but at
the end of the line we have a hard time
defending the D5 Pawn because that
Bishop on B3 it also guards the D1
Square so black will snag that pawn on
D5 and actually have a pawn for the
exchange not ideal not ideal let's try
to think of an alternative something
that eliminates Black's counter play
entirely
okay so Rook A5 does come to mind to hit
C5 that's one possibility
also possible is the very awkward
looking move Rook to A3 it looks awkward
because we're using an entire Rook to
defend against a trivial threat but it's
really not a trivial threat we do not
want to give up this Pawn we need that
the you know the big boys to do the
heavy lifting here what else is The Rook
going to do nothing I don't see a single
compelling reason we shouldn't play Rook
A3 here
again awkward looking move but if you
look one step further we can follow up
with Rook to C1 so we're just gonna have
to bear with this for one move and then
the Rook can move up to A5
Bishop E6 exactly is not going anywhere
The Rook cannot be okay our opponent is
collapsing with E6 and trying to give up
a second punch to free up the stroke
which is an understandable reaction but
it's it's from the frying pan into the
fire so what should we take with well
let's think about that for a second Pawn
takes E6 I think is more tempting for
most people but it has to be calculated
because as a result the bishop is going
to be a little bit trapped on F7 so the
positional move is just to take back
with the bishop that's the move which
requires less calculation
and less calculation given our time
situation is good
so let's take on E6 with the bishop okay
Bishop D6
our opponent sacks the exchange for
activity not a bad move at all by the
way and in a classical game I would
consider refraining from Bishop takes D7
because blackplay's Bishop takes F4 and
you know the G5 Pawn Falls and a rook is
passive so I wouldn't grab that
immediately let's continue trying to
play while eliminating any semblance of
counter play I think we have a really
cool move here I think we have a really
cool move here
so can we keep the tension between the
two Bishops what do you know about
situations where the Bishops are staring
at each other like this well off
oftentimes you want to do what's called
trading on your own terms you should
know this if you play the London system
yep I like Bishop G3 this is a really
nice looking move
and if black takes which way do we take
well you might say well I learned that I
have to take toward the center but this
is an end game we have to think more
concretely let's take with the F Pawn to
open up the f file for our rook and we
can now play H4 and solidify the G5 Pawn
so this is no longer a weakness
what are the other problems that we
should solve here well I'm irritated by
this darn Bishop on CD let's get it the
hell out of there should we go Rook C1
well no then why did we take on uh G3
with the F1 let's play Rook F2 keeping
the Rook on the f file and chasing the
bishop away then we can drag this other
Rook around and it can finally rejoin
Society it's done its job on on on on A3
okay
and we definitely need to stay very
precise here this is not over we're up
two pawns but our opponent is defending
very resiliently and we're low on time
there's a really cool trick if our
opponent plays Bishop to D1 trying to
stay tied down to the B3 Pawn we have a
super cool tactic there that I think
wins the game hopefully we get a chance
to experience and no Bishop G6 okay
so next priority right when you're in
time pressure it's important to keep
your priorities in mind and and sort of
work on them very directly next priority
is for us to improve the placement of
our work how do we do that we can lift
it up through A4 to F4 I think that is
the clinical approach
we could also of course have played Rook
A1 it doesn't really matter but I think
this is even better
because here The Rook has even access to
like H4 like if black plays H6 we can
play maybe even Rook H4
doesn't matter these are Minor Details
we're in time pressure as long as we get
the big picture right we'll be fine
okay eight seconds for our opponent he
might flag King E7
okay so now let's complete our maneuver
with Rook a to F4 doubling up on the
open file this is logical and we have
two approaches I think to continue
converting this Advantage we can of
course at some point play the move C4 to
solidify the D5 Pawn but we don't need
to rush with this move why not because
the D5 Pawn is very safely protected by
the bishop on what other sides of the
board can we continue expanding and
continue making improvements well you
probably noticed the move Rook f8 which
forces The Rook trade that's okay but we
can play Rook f8 whenever we want to I'm
also looking at the king side what do we
have on the king side we have a pawn
majority well let's push our Pawn
majority and try to run G4 and H5 up the
board
in order either to create a past Pawn in
the event the black plays H6 or to push
black off the board entirely because the
bishop on G6 is going to be caught on
the crossfire
Bishop E8
okay I think Rook f8
it's a perfect time to play Rook f8
perhaps let me think
no let's start with G4 let's let's be
consecutive right let's let's follow up
with G4
grabbing more space on the king side
depriving the bishop of more Escape
squares
and we're just pushing black and pushing
black off the board we're making small
gradual improving moves
like now is the perfect time to play
Rook f8 why well because it is I think
Rook Cafe
is a good opportunity to simplify the
game we're in time pressure so this
makes it easier for us to play
and it applies more pressure on the
bishop Bishop G6 okay
wow opponent defending very very well I
have to say this is impressive
okay is that for a little GM magic here
let's deliver a check on d8 to dislodge
the king from its blockading post
let's see where the King goes it's hard
to say I mean our next move depends on
where the King goes and obviously if
black plays King C7 which I'm
anticipating
there's also King E5 two seconds for our
opponent he's gonna okay can you five
now I have to calculate
because I see a really beautiful no it
doesn't work okay
E5 is very strong actually I didn't
quite anticipate that
okay I have to think
okay Bishop H5
forcing the bishop out
Bishop C2
okay now we're gonna go Bishop to G8
which is a weird move but it's actually
a pretty normal move because we're
preparing to push the d-pawn forward
and we could not have done that
immediately because well because the
bishop on E6 would have hung now we can
push D6 and what do you notice about the
move D6 well what you notice is that the
Rook is literally trapped that's also
why I played Bishop G8 The Rook is now
trapped and the game is over
the game is over because the Rook is no
squares E6 is covered F7 covered E8
covered t7 C7 both covered opponent
resigns major props on a super resilient
defense I mean if he brought us down to
the last seconds
to those who freak out about the clock I
am aware of the clock at all times
you know it's almost like I hate
turbulence but you know it's not
dangerous because you know the pilots
are in control
so I'm not going to let us lose on time
uh borrowing an internet problem so what
you should understand is that you know
20 seconds a lot of time and if things
get down to a Time scramble I will make
a move eventually
nor am I doing this for show I'm I'm
trying to fit in as much explanation as
possible to clue you in on why I do what
I do even when I'm in time pressure so
sometimes I maybe you would in your eyes
needlessly drop down to you know five
seconds ten seconds but I want to keep
everybody involved in the process
the lesson is don't worry about it
okay
so first things first this is an opening
themed speed run so we need to get our
allop and Bible out and see what on
Earth I did wrong because we definitely
should have gotten a bigger Advantage
than we got and I'll take this brief
opportunity to thank everybody who
subscribes to the YouTube If you enjoy
the content you know and you want to
help me keep getting it out regularly a
sub really really helps the goal is 500k
by December which is probably
unachievable but
um every every sub count so thank you to
everybody who supports all right let's
get the elephant Bible out to those who
need a refresher on the book this is
called squeezing the Sicilian by
Alexander calaflon and Sergey sullivov
which is I think one of the best new
books on the album there are quite a few
books on the elephant but this one is
one of my favorites
so Queen a4check is correct
you might remember that in our first
game we played Bishop B5 check their
followed Knight bd7 which is the best
move then we played
how did that how did that game go I
think we played D4 our opponent played
A6 we dropped the bishop back to E2
our opponent
played
I want to say now our opponent
recaptured the pawn we played Knight F3
or we I think we played C4 Knight F6 and
D5 this is how the game went
and does anybody remember how black is
supposed to equalize in this position if
this is actually the reason why
Queen A4 check is a superior move too
Bishop B5 trick this line is very
theoretical it's very it's well known
and Yazi with five Subs as well geez
Louise yes it's B5 to play this benko
Gambit Style
this is actually how our game continued
C takes B5 and here our opponent I think
might have made a mistake the correct
move is Knight to B6 and black is going
to win back the D5 pawn and pure black
equalizes white is not better here I
checked this with a high level engine
this is not the way to go so Queen A4
check is the more testing approach
so our opponent played Bishop D7 which
is one of the moves that they give
Bishop D7 Queen B3 is correct Queen B6
is correct If instead black plays Queen
C7 then simply Bishop C4 and this check
is harmless in view of 92. yeah this is
dumb now Queen V6 is obligatory Bishop
C4 is correct Knight A6 is correct so
we're following caliphun's line Knight
F3 Knight C7 and here they say aha so
their main recommendation is D4 but they
also give 95 as an interesting
alternative and I was right after Queen
takes B3 we committed a serious
inaccuracy by playing Pawn takes B3 and
I fell victim to exactly the same thing
I warned people about which is over
Reliance on kind of general principles I
allowed myself to be guided by the
general principle of opening up the a
file this is a good opportunity for me
to show you some of the openings in
which Queen B3 Queen B6 is standard
mostly this happens in D4 based opening
so in the London system you get this
very often uh so for instance one of the
main lines of the London goes Bishop F4
Knight F6 E3 so E6 this can happen in
various move orders but the bottom line
is uh C5 C3 Knight C6 Knight bd2 so here
for example Queen B6 is a very standard
very standard way to play and white
responds oftentimes with Queen B3 and
you have this exact standoff where you
know black doesn't want to be the one to
take on B3 and as you can confirm with
the engine white is supposed to take
here not with the Knight but with the
pawn and here white holds a serious
Advantage also in This Love in This Love
as some of you are indicating you also
get a lot of Queen V3 Queen b6s so what
are what are some variations of the slav
in which you get Queen B3 Queen V6 let
me think for a second well in the
chabanenko slav the chabanenko slav
being this move A6 you do often see
white being the one to play Queen V3 in
the G3 slot you get Queen B3 Queen B6 so
if white plays G3 that's actually what I
play you do see Queen B3 Queen B6
occasionally played in this line you
also see it in like this version of the
G3 slab if black plays Bishop F5 here I
think one of the main lines goes Queen
B3 and black gets the queen out to B6
and it's the same drill where normally
you'll see these Queens staring at each
other for a while White's best move here
according to opening Explorer is either
C5 trying to force black to be the one
to take on B3 or dropping the queen back
to C7 and now the bishop can come out
with Tempo and uh the line goes on so
okay you get the point the point is the
standoff of the Queens on B3 and B6 is
very standard and the main
characteristic of that stand is that
neither side typically wants to be the
one to capture the opposing sides Queen
even though it slightly damages the pawn
structure because the pawn structure is
subservient to piece placement and peace
activity and control of squares okay so
Bishop C4 Knight A6 Knight F3 knight
c795 uh their main move by the way
is D4 they claim that D4 also gives an
advantage and they give the following
lines Queen takes B3
now you play Pawn takes V3 interesting
so here you take back with a pawn
CD4 Knight D4 it is also possible for
white to choose here D6
creating an isolated Pawn in his
opponent's position this is a Desperado
sack because you're going to lose the
pawn anyway so you want to ruin Black's
Pawn structure while you're at it and
you get a slight advantage in the end
game Bishop B2 Bishop C5 Bishop E3
Knight G4
Bishop takes Bishop takes F3 Bishop back
King up and they give plus equals which
seems reasonable I think white is
slightly better here so this is one
possibility or instead of D6 you can
play the No Frills move Knight takes D5
uh by black and here they claim that
white has a small but stable advantage
in hamara coolav Guerrero Arroyo Spain
2008 some game black has regained his
sacrificed Pawn but is still too far
from reaching complete equality now one
piece of advice if you're using opening
books or you're using a chessable course
yes you have to learn the moves that are
that are given in the book or in the
chorus but it's always a good idea to
spend you know a couple of minutes
analyzing the position on which the
author stops right so here call ofman
stops his analysis and says that white
is better so it's always a good idea to
really feel like you understand the
resulting middle games and one way to do
that is just to kind of open open-ended
analysis with the engine just make some
moves get a sense for how you want to
develop your pieces and get a sense for
why your position is good why is white
better here it's not immediately obvious
why white is better here but the engine
confirms that he is
so let's say black plays E6 I think
there's a couple of factors that work in
White's favor of course there's the a
file which we've talked about there's
the nice placement of White's pieces in
the center and here the engine gives the
move B4
why
play before who can tell me a specific
reason
other than okay grabbing space obviously
but what's the more concrete reason to
play before it's prophylactic what are
we preventing
we're preventing Black's Bishop from
developing to C5 why is it dangerous for
Black's Bishop to develop to C5 because
we want to keep our Knight on D4 and the
absolute last thing that we want
although the engine here does give
Knight to F3 the last thing we want is
this transformation where black has a
massive blockading Knight
so I really like the look of B4 so let's
say black plays Bishop B7 where is this
Knight gonna go well the engine gives
Knight D2 castles and now Knight two to
F3 and I think it's becoming clear why
white is better here white just has a
big space Advantage the knights coming
into E5 let's say black plays A6 now you
can bring the bishop out to g595 rookie
one why does a bunch of ways to improve
his position and this just seems very
very pleasant very pleasant for white
so
I like that recommendation in the next
game we will play D4 but instead in this
game we played 95 and again the best
move here was to take back with the
bishop what's the difference well if
black plays Bishop F5 here as I've
already explained at this point we have
the move C4
and at a higher level of opening
analysis you have to treat things very
very concretely you might look at this
and say wait a second if C4 is good here
why can't we just play C4 here isn't
this the same thing well it's not the
same thing because the Queens are still
on the board in this position
who can remind me of Black's best move
in this position and if you're watching
on YouTube you should pause the video
kind of refresh your memory on that yes
it's E6 trading off the pawns and
hopefully you'll remember that black has
full compensation for the sacrificed
Pawn in the form of massive control over
the D4 square and I've talked about this
at length in other videos comparing and
contrasting is a great way to build up
your opening understanding so take that
instance of C4 and compare it to this
instance of C4 what's the difference
well if black plays E6 white is actually
essentially winning on the spot
so here the difference is that black is
just unable to remove this Pawn wedge
there is a check on A4 this is
devastating because King E7 runs into
the beautiful D6 deflection and then you
win The Rook
of course black has the move B5 here but
after CB white is threatening B6 this is
losing
black is getting destroyed here of
course E6 is impossible but if black
doesn't play E6 well what is black gonna
do Bishop A4 is a huge threat black
cannot Castle because F7 is lost the
engine gives Knight D7 but now white
just trades and uh White can develop D3
Knight C3 whatever Knight C3 E6 and
white doesn't have to take on E6 this
would give black control over the D4
Square much like in the other instance
but here white could just ignore and
castle and if black takes then well we
could flick in the move rookie one check
and force the king out of the way or the
bishop to E7 and just look at this
position this is disaster D6 is coming
D3 Bishop F4 and black is you know out
of breath here so
again everything in the opening is
concrete a move that is bad in one
position could be good in another and a
higher rated you know the more you have
to appreciate this Nuance the lower
rated you are the more you can get away
with just sort of memorizing a couple of
opening lines a couple of principles and
following those principles but not to
get too bogged down if if we had taken
back with the bishop our opponent would
have taken on D5 with a knight and my
intention here was to take on D7
and play the move D3 and I think white
is solidly better here because we have
the bishop pair and we have very clear
prospects for our other minor pieces on
the queen side for example Knight D2
Knight F3 is a great maneuver to contest
the key Central squares and if black
overextends himself with E5 we can use
that pawn as a Target and put a rook on
E1 Bishop B3 to A4 check uh could be a
very problematic move sometimes like if
black plays rookie 8 that is already a
blunder
so here you can see a clear example of
like the bishop pair being a really good
thing
Okay so
is a mistake why is it a mistake so once
again it's because now this bishop is
stuck in the Nether world and what I
wouldn't give to be able to put the pawn
on top of the bishop I saw Bishop F5 but
falsely believed that D6 refutes the
line ed6 Knight F7 and this looks great
for white but as you guys correctly
pointed out D5 is what I missed from a
distance this is an interference move if
you move the bishop you lose the Knight
if you take the Rook you're going to
lose the bishop and subsequently you're
also going to lose the Knight there's
this classic maneuver G6 Bishop G7 and
the Knight is lost but actually this is
a very instructive moment who can tell
me Black's best move in this position
who can tell me Black's best move in
this position it's not G6 because
remember the Knight isn't going anywhere
it can't be evacuated by any other
pieces so you should take this
opportunity to make it as difficult to
make life as difficult as possible for
white
what does it mean to make life difficult
here what means to make development
difficult or what does it mean to make
development difficult well what
development is white intending well
primarily the the development of this
bishop and the development of this
Knight for both to happen white needs to
push the D4 the pawn up to D4 so we put
the bishop on top of the pawn right we
just sit on white we also prevent
castling look at how much stuff this
bishop accomplishes alone why does
close to Big borderline lost here like
white has to figure out a way to get
around the bishop with something like F3
but now black and calmly develop his
other bishop and then just walk the king
over to G8 and win back the Knight and
the bishop is unassailable
like if you move the Rook then you also
lose this Pawn
and if you try to trap the bishop then
the other Knight comes in and white just
doesn't have the Machinery to keep
everything uh in order here
so this is a classic type of technique
where Knights and Bishops on the D6
Square are unbelievably strong if
especially if there is a piece like on
C1 or on C8 whose development uh you are
blocking I I want a couple of nice games
using this technique uh one of them was
against a GM
who really underestimated the effect of
and the effectiveness
of this particular
type of development so here it is
this is a game that I played in 2013
against Ukrainian gmundry buff
okay this will have to do and this was a
Rosalina season so completely different
opening
but he plays this very dubious line with
with E5 and what immediately jumps out
at you
about the move E5 well it's the fact
that it weakens the D6 square and you
might say well black is going to play
Pawn D6 and fill that square with a pawn
but he doesn't do that I played Knight
A3 played Knight C4 he still doesn't
play D6 I played D4 to blast open the
center sacrificing a pawn
he accepts the sacrifice Queen F3
castles and already white is like
borderline winning here with Bishop F4
and Knight D6 and you can see the
similarity black simply is playing
Without a Queen side even if black plays
B6 the Knight controls The Bishop's only
developing Square so I won the game and
I could spend a while
you know analyzing the aim but but the
entire game block plays without his
Queen side he tries to wiggle his way
out of it but he fails and ultimately
I transformed the queen side pressure
into a king side attack the Knight jumps
back to F5 at the rights at the right
time notice that white is black is still
playing without all these pieces
what's the idea if gf5 Bishop H6 leads
to Checkmate because F6 is impossible to
pawn is pinned
so the queen has to move I eliminate the
fianchetto bishop and then I take this
Pawn
black is riddled Black's position is
riddled with weaknesses
um Knight takes E5 is a tactical attempt
but I just checkmated him Bishop F6 is a
nice final flourish
and I drove his King out and then I I
checkmated it so the takeaway again is
the power of that Knight on D6
the other game that I had in mind
just a moment the other game that I
remembered on this topic
was a much older game and I think this
one is a bit less
uh eye-popping but you still will
hopefully understand the
the uh similarity
okay so here it is
this is a really old game this is right
before the world youth Chess
Championship in 2012. completely
different opening but again he goes E5
because 97 so you can see where this is
going and
he allows the move Knight D6 which is
actually really really bad and he never
recovers from the fact that he gives up
his light Square Bishop so here it's not
that I'm sitting on D6 it's that I'm
using it as a jumping off point to uh to
eliminate the bishop but without the
light squared Bishop his light squares
are horribly weak as is the D6 square
and ultimately he pays the the price for
that the price for lacking a light
squared Bishop because I'm operating
entirely on the light squares in this
game
all everything on the light squares
Queen H5
Bishop F5 and the game is won entirely
on the light squares
um there was a similar famous game
between petrogen and Pacman
where petrogen did something something
similar anyways not to belabor the point
you get it
just remember the power of putting
something on D3 or on D6 uh when there
is an entire Queen side that's
undeveloped
um okay so where were we
so all of this was in service of
explaining why D6 is a bad move here
Knight F7 I remind you if you invert the
move order it's even worse because black
can save uh the piece with Knight E6
um so instead I kind of accepted the
inevitable and decided to get the night
out to A3 which I think is quite a good
move and I think our opponent responded
very accurately with A6 this is a very
high level move a lot of people would
have automatically taken on D5 and here
we would have probably still played G4
by the way
but if black would have taken with the
other Knight here I would have played
Knight to B5 and this is very
problematic for black this is very
problematic for black because black is
under a lot of strain in the center and
black is under a lot of strain on the
king side
and if black plays E6 then I think we
can get away with uh snagging this Pawn
on A7 the Knight can evacuate back
through B5
so yeah Knight f65 we would have played
Knight B5 of course taking is uh
suicidal because Knight F7 is coming
next so A6 was a very patient
prophylactic move realizing that this
Pawn isn't actually going anywhere okay
so we castled black plays Knight C takes
D5 and now I'm actually really really
happy with the move G4 this spices up
the position I remind you there are a
couple of ideas of this movement so how
do you find a move like this well
okay I can't lead you by the hand and
pretend like every one of these moves is
easy to find with some sort of algorithm
but as I pointed out anytime you have
two nights that are defending each other
and you're making contact
with one of the knights you should
already be looking for ways to chase the
other night away with a pawn right and
if I phrase it like that then G4 should
become pretty obvious you should also
understand that this Knight is kind of
overloaded it has a clear responsibility
so it's not really controlling any of
the squares on uh on on the king side I
could probably even find you some games
where uh where white orchestrated this
exact maneuver
this exact maneuver
uh to win to win a piece I'll run a
little search while I'm talking about
this position let's see what I can find
this is not a well-known game
a Bulgarian women's tournament
it looks like a pretty straightforward
end game but you can see the similarity
there's a bishop on C4 there's a knight
on D5
guess what white plays here guess what
white plays here
well white plays the move G4
now black makes a mistake black makes a
very instructive mistake the best move I
think would have been to drop back to E6
much like our opponent did in the game
but black the The Rook is defending the
Knight the Knight is defending the
Knight I'm not worried about white
playing G5 because I can just move my
knight away big deal big deal the rook's
defending the Knight what did black Miss
what very pretty sequence did black Miss
very nice bouncing across you should
notice the black is a weak back rank so
white takes on D5 anyway and Rook takes
a seven wins a big pawn and gets The
Rook to a very active square and then
white went around and won a second Pawn
on B6
I can mango for the prime
so just one example of this uh type of
idea in in the wild and combine that
with a very perceptive tactical vision
and you get really really nice sequences
and white won the game
okay
so we go back to the speedrun game
yeah so G4 right this is not a
particularly uncommon type of idea here
we force black to play Bishop E6 because
Bishop G6 would have simply lost a piece
to G5 and I remind you what is the
benefit of forcing this bishop onto E6
well there's a couple
the entire game black struggled to bring
the dark squared Bishop out this was
where it started because we're
preventing black from playing E6 but the
main idea is that we open up new
prospects for art night the Knight drops
back to C2 preparing the central
expansion with D4 when we have a
development advantage or you have more
active pieces you want to open up the
center that helps you you know exploit
that and that's exactly what we're doing
with the move Knight C2
okay once once castles happens which I
missed by the way we have to reassess
the situation and realize that Knight
takes G4 is a threat so we took care of
that by playing G5
forcing the Knight back a couple of
questions K sandwich asks is Knight B5
possible instead of Knight C2 so I
talked about this during the game I will
ask you K sandwich what is the threat
that you pose with the movement ip5
what's your next move going to be
right the problem is you're not
threatening I'm not trying to be
sarcastic I'm trying to help you
develop a method of testing whether
these moves are actually good the threat
is non-existent because C7 is defended I
can also move my Rook back and this is
the main reason that you don't want to
play Knight P5 here I reinforce the
threat of taking the Knight so the
Knight just has to ignominiously drop
back to A3 I guess my point isn't very
good because white actually does have a
threat White's threat I guess is to play
G5
and then play Bishop takes D5 and then
deliver a fork on C7 but it's way too
cumbersome and black has time to move
the Rook away does that make sense now
the Knight is attacked and you have to
move the Knight back
but the way that I'm able to see that is
is by noticing that Knight C7 isn't
actually a threat here okay we've got a
couple of other questions
what's the eval after G4 it's about so
it's an edge for white it's about 0.7 or
0.8 uh Shabazz Bishop takes G4 we play
Knight takes G4 and the Knight on D5 is
lost in the end okay so on we go Bishop
E6 Knight C2 castles with G5 Knight is
forced back we trade and we play D4
and I will admit that there was one uh
very powerful defensive resource that I
missed I think at a Grand Master Level
not even at a gym like a high level
Bishop F5 is the decisive mistake after
Bishop takes D5 black is losing black is
objectively lost I just confirmed this
with the engine who can remind me of a
better way to do the same thing Black's
concept is the correct one which is this
bishop has to be developed at all costs
so you might say well then let's go G6
but hey we're attacking the C5 pawn and
this actually isn't just a pawn white
can now use this Pawn as a battering ram
and shatter Black's King position this
is a disaster
so you need to figure out some way to
get this Pawn to E6 Bishop F5 was the
right call Bishop H3 would have been the
right execution because it hits the Rook
The Rook has to move and now black and
play E6 but I don't actually think that
this solves all of Black's problems and
I just confirmed that with the engine
how should white proceed in this
position there is a very concrete
approach that gives white a big Queen
side attack
if you're watching on YouTube I would
recommend that you pause and try to
puzzle out this this sequence it's not
easy
it's definitely not easy
so it's not Bishop takes D5 and C4
that's an interesting proposal but again
what do you accomplish by playing C4 I
just dropped my Rook back and you've
given up a very important piece you're a
light squared Bishop now your light
squares are going to be super weak
ecstatic gotta you deserve a sub D takes
C5 Bishop C5 and suddenly you start
pushing the B Pawn now why on Earth
would you do that well again that Rook
on A1 has tremendous power in this game
let's say the bishop moves back
somewhere white plays B5 and hopefully
you can see the trouble that black is
now in because if a takes B5
Roque wins The Rook in the corner in
fact even better would be to first to
First Take on D5
and then play Rook A8 and Rook takes h8
winning an entire Rook
so I call this potential energy right
kinetic versus potential energy in in
pieces is something I've talked about in
previous speed runs where the Rook
running one has a lot of potential
energy it doesn't have any current
energy because it's just biting on
granite but the moment the a file opens
up that Rook is going to be the
game-winning piece and appreciating
pieces like this Rook can be very hard
because you might be looking at it only
in the short term but the moment black
castled queen side
you know I
pointed out during the game that the
king isn't actually that safe here and
one of the reasons why is that if the a
file opens Rook A8 is going to be
devastating in many many types of
situations
so okay so Bishop H3 rookie one E6 DC
Bishop C5 B4 Bishop B6 is maybe a better
move we still play B5 and if black tries
to keep the a file plugged who can tell
me White's follow-up move this is really
pretty
wait to play here
and it's the same theme again this Rook
and it's the power of having doubled
pawns which can be a good thing B4 the
other Pawn comes in
right blacks simply cannot keep the
spawn alive
uh night before is interesting but it
doesn't really threaten anything again
it's the same problem because black
defends the Knight on D5 sufficient
times yeah B4 and you might say oh but
aren't we blundering C3 but what we're
giving up C3 but we're recapturing A5
and then we're gonna push A6 and this is
a monster past pawn and Black's King is
wide open and R king is completely safe
uh so hopefully that makes a certain
degree of sense I already think that
black is in trouble here but Bishop H3
might have afforded more practical
chances Bishop F5 Bishop D5 is just game
over
pole Cryer asks what about 93 instead of
D take C5 to trade off
one of Black's only good pieces great
question
uh so you're proposing after Bishop H3
rookie one E6 to play Knight E3 I think
it's a reasonable move but okay black
can drop the Knight back to B6 what have
you really accomplished by chasing
Black's Knight out of the center it's
not all that much also you're
experiencing some logistical problems
because if you move your Bishop then I
will then I can I can take on D4 and I
can get my Bishop out and black seizes
the initiative so it's just that DC and
B4 is much much uh more effective here
so here we play Bishop takes D5 and
again the point is that this this this
loses an exchange for black because
we're hitting both of these pieces and
The Rook can't keep the bishop protected
and Bishop H3 doesn't work obviously
because at the end of the line you
recapture the bishop and white is up a
piece okay so our opponent chose the
Lesser Evil by giving up F7 but it's not
just any pawn that black loses it's a
crucial Pawn because now black is
permanently devoid of the possibility of
pushing the epon so his King side is
gonna remain forever paralyzed as it
basically did in the game
I think really the game-winning move
though was D5 this is the key follow-up
because I think a lot of people would
take automatically think oh I'm winning
a second pawn and this would allow black
to get his pieces out and I cannot
emphasize enough that in a position like
this yes white is probably better but
not by much because suddenly Black's
pieces are super well placed and White's
pieces are all over the place and maybe
we can play a move like Bishop E3 but
now black will trade and get the Rook
into the second Rank and you know black
acquires significant compensation for
the pawn
so here prophylactic thinking is reign
supreme where you first and foremost
have to ask yourself what is my
opponent's next move and if you phrase
it that way well it's pretty obvious
right the king side is undeveloped black
wants to play E6 or maybe even E5 Bishop
F4 would incidentally walk into E5 and
black wins a piece
the moment you realize that the move D5
should be evident to you because E5 runs
into onpassant you're just preventing
Black's only way of getting his pieces
out
perfect game to illustrate this concept
an old old game of mine
and I think it it nicely illustrates the
power of of prophylactic thinking as
it's called thinking in terms of what
your opponent wants and how to prevent
it this was one of the first games where
I kind of did that successfully so this
position is where we're going to start
looking uh this was Super K through four
uh Nationals in in Houston 2005.
so in this position I decided to
sacrifice a piece I played the obvious
move Rook takes A6 why is this a peace
sacrifice well black plays C5 this is
what my opponent was relying on and the
Knight can't move because you lose the
queen
now Queen A1 getting the queen into the
attack uh hooking up the queen in The
Rook
C takes D4 and in this position I found
a move that I was really really proud of
so just by me saying that you should
know that it's not Bishop takes D4 why
did I reject just recapturing well
what's the big worry here the big worry
for me was that Black's King was going
to escape into the center or worse yet
onto the queen side onto the king side
so there's the Mover Kay check which I
know all of you guys are looking at but
this actually helps black do what he
wants to do anyway this looks incredibly
tempting but it just forces the king to
a spot that it wants to go anyway
thinking prophylactically yields a super
strong move that essentially keeps
Black's King imprisoned on the queen
side uh this is the queen side I know it
sounds weird but that allows white to
surround the king with the remaining
pieces rooked a seven the quiet move
now of course it's reliant on some
tactics d e Queen A6 check Queen B6
check and queen C7 is an easy mate
uh but black brought the queen back now
I can calmly take on D4 the king is
stuck it's under lock and key and black
can do nothing about this Rook Rook D7
there's a check on A8 familiar tactic by
the way right again this rule K-8
winning the other Rook after Knight F6 I
brought my other Rook into the attack
and after Knight T5 I found a really
pretty winning sequence Rook drops back
to A6
forcing the queen to the seventh rank
now it's time for a check and The Rook
drops back to A7 again pinning the queen
and winning the queen so anyways
prophylactic thinking even in tactical
position what does my opponent want how
do I prevent it how do I make it as hard
as possible for my opponent to
accomplish his aims both General and
specific
and the key takeaways that this applies
not just to like actual threats like oh
my piece is hanging let's move it but to
conceptual ideas as well E6 is a threat
even though it doesn't win anything
because it improves your opponent's
position tremendously and that's why D5
is so powerful
okay so King d8 and again Bishop F4
really like this move what does our
opponent want he probably wants G6 let's
prevent it by preparing Bishop E5 in
response which would win the black is
paralyzed H6 G6
if black plays B6 then black loses the
A6 Pawn
this is technically a fork but this is
technically a Checkmate another benefit
of putting the bishop on F4 it blocks
the king's escape to the seventh rank
but it's a GMO but I think everybody
should find it you should at least
understand the logic behind it and you
should remember that E5 runs into on
Passat this is an important tactical
detail otherwise you lose a piece black
is in zuk Swan Bishop C2 and now we
calmly play an awkward looking move but
we just eliminate all of Black's counter
play so again why didn't we play Bishop
E6 because I didn't want to give black a
chance to sack The Exchange and win the
pawn on D5 and once the D5 Pawn is one
black will finally be able to bring his
King side out definitely didn't want to
allow that so there's no hurry black is
paralyzed That's The Power of keeping
your opponent paralyzed you have all the
time in the world to do whatever it is
you want to do okay E6 is desperation
but I think black is dead lost anyway
how would I play with black here I would
probably play Bishop E4 but then white
can just go C4 I would just resign this
is game over
K sandwich asks what if black had played
G6 here yes this would have been the
best move agreed G6 here was Black's
last chance to develop his Bishop but I
still think we would have played Bishop
F4 and here we have a move that I
mentioned during the game I think it
wins a third Pawn in this position who
can spot this devastating move
this is a move that should be on your
radar
it should be on your radar Rook A5 very
nice
now why is this move good here because
black doesn't have B6 because then black
loses A6 and we double on the a file and
win black has no way to defend C7 this
bishop on F4 is preventing black from
playing Rook C7 so Black's gonna lose a
third pawn and obviously the or a second
Pawn rather but once C5 is lost the king
is driven into the center and the other
Bishop can come back this is lost so
that's the answer
uh one more thing note that after Rook
f8 takes here we have Bishop E6 very
important tactical detail that in this
position The Rook on uh D7 is hanging
otherwise we would lose our Bishop
okay so that's important and after Rook
D3 we have a check
and now we can play Bishop B6 and Rook
C8 is Unstoppable checkmate
okay so what did we have in the game
well we had E6 the bishop E6 Bishop D6
Bishop G3 I really like this move
because it trades on our own terms and
we open up the file same concept as the
queen standoff on B3 and B6 again if
you're a London player this should be
second nature too this bishop G3 kind of
move what do I mean by that if you're
not allowed to player well
again in the London one of the most
standard sequences is Bishop D6 which is
met with Bishop G3 now of course here
you're not trying to take with the F
Pawn you're trying to take toward the
center and open up the file but it's the
same principle just translated to a
different file in the game
in the sense that we
play F takes G3 in order to open up
access to the F7 Square then
we chased the bishop away there was one
further detail in response to Bishop D1
we had a really sexy move
okay it's it's straightforward but it's
reliant on a really cool tactic who can
spot this straightforward but nice move
it's not D6 I would say this is
premature because of a rook C6 and why
have you you've you've created an
additional weakness
it's not Rook D2 I don't want to move
this Rook away from the f-file can we do
it with the other Rook that's a hint can
you do it with the other Rook
turns out that you can Rook to A1
and if you look carefully you have now
the move D6 that's it
double attack on the rook and then
discovered attack on the bishop
and of course black can continue playing
here but this is dead lost black is up a
full exchange what is up a full Exchange
so here I would have played Rook A1 this
is what I was hoping would happen
not taking no for an answer now we play
Rook A4 we lift The Rook up I don't
think my technique was ideal if you look
at this with an engine you'll probably
find that I made some inaccuracies but I
think it's a moot point we never let the
win slip we're up two pawns and now we
just expand a little bit on the king
side patient play G4 there's no hurry
black has no plan
and now we decided to trade Rooks
note that after Bishop D7 we would have
forced a winning Pawn end game with Rook
to d8 this is actually a pretty
important detail you don't want a rook
end game because Rook end games tend to
be very drush
Rook d a check uh in response to King C7
you should not play D6 check I think
this is a move which would be very
tempting to some people but after King
takes eight you've just given away your
pawn and white is probably still winning
after Bishop F5 but why why is this
necessary just give a check
and now you can even go B4 CB and C4 and
this Pawn decides the game or or you can
start with C4 and then play B4 and C5 so
plenty of ways to win King E5 H5 is is
game over
and I really like Bishop G8 I think this
is the last flourish avoiding blundering
the bishop and black just has no way to
stop D6 The Rook is literally just
trapped here that's it
D6 and our opponent resigned because the
Rook is trapped
so again the final like 10 15 moves were
in time pressure and should be taken to
the grain of salt I don't think my
endgame technique was perfect but I
think it was it was sufficient to win
the game so that was complicated that
was very a lot of meat on the bone there
key takeaways from this game what's the
tldr first of all in in terms of the
theory Queen A4 check is the best move
against the delayed D5 variation
our biggest mistake was to play so D4
here is a very good move but after 95
it's crucial to take back with the
Bishops secure the bishop pair and enjoy
your life in that end game remember that
Knight A3 is a very typical move in the
alopin and the Knight B5 is not the only
idea you can drop the Knight back to C2
and prepare D4
then uh one of the critical of course D4
uh finding the opportunity to push the
pawn and Bishop takes D5 being
constantly on alert for tactics even in
positions where they seem very unlikely
and doing you know crossing your t's
dotting your eyes always considering
captures even if just for a single
second and once the pawn Was Won oh
sorry keep doing that once the pawn Was
Won uh I think the game-winning moves
were D5 and Bishop F4 both moves aimed
at prophylaxis stopping your opponent's
threats uh positional and Tactical
all right guys I think that concludes
the presentation that probably took over
an hour I put all of my effort into that
explanation
uh but for now everybody thanks have a
good one and bye
foreign
[Music]